all 12 of those Thai boys and their
soccer coach have been saved from the
underworld okay very nice story
very nice yeah it's a historic moment
this is the first it's actually the most
Americans have ever cared about any
soccer team ever
we've never pay attention to soccer
teams until now right they're in a cave
we have speaking of historic we have our
Supreme Court nominee Brett Cavanaugh
has been announced president Kyle yeah
president Trump's Supreme Court nominee
Brett Cavanaugh once wrote that
president should be shielded from
criminal charges while in office he once
wrote that yeah yeah he didn't write
this in a ruling he wrote it on a cake
he sent to trump three days ago
tip the tip the scale it's a good cake
president Trump is headed to England did
you know that on his trip to Great
Britain President Trump is going to meet
Queen Elizabeth yeah he's gonna ask the
Queen about brexit immigration and how
to stay in power for 60 years in
questions on the eve of president
Trump's visit to the UK the BBC is
airing a documentary called Trump is the
president a sex pest yeah it's a
10-second documentary that features a
woman saying yes just credits come down
yeah I've never heard the term sex
Paget's it's what they call them over
though those what they call them over
200 people in the Midwest have been
sickened from a parasite found in Del
Monte vegetables yeah isn't that
incredible 200 people in the mid Midwest
eat vegetables
a teenage boy in China went to the
hospital because he got a USB cord stuck
in his penis doctors say the boy is now
in good health and running the latest
version of Windows
[Applause]
you